The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: I
think it's a nice topic
to end this semester, because
in a way, it brings together,
I think, some of the
main threads that we've
through this semester.
But also, in fact, the
last point of the text,
alliteration I can sense my
point to wait into the future.
So without further ado, we have
Lorraine, Will, and Cynthia.
GUEST SPEAKER: So this is
our presentation on language
resistance and liberation.
Welcome to the
last day of class.
Congratulations (CHUCKLING)
for getting this far.
So as the road map, we're
going to go through first
"Rethinking Literacy,
A Dialogue,"
the piece by Freire and Macedo.
Macedo?
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
Freire and Macedo.
GUEST SPEAKER: Macedo?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Macedo.
GUEST SPEAKER: Macedo.
And then we're going to look
at the "Literacy and Critical
Pedagogy" piece, and then end
with the MIT Haiti initiatives.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK.
So this is just a little bit
of a background on the writers
of the first two pieces.
Both of them are educators
in critical pedagogy.
And one is from Brazil, and
one is Cape Verdean-American.
GUEST SPEAKER: So
in the first piece,
Freire mentions the premise--
the main premises of culture,
and I think that
these are really
important to keep in mind,
because this is a really
interesting and, I think,
powerful way to frame culture.
The first one is that cultural
processes are intimately
connected with social relations,
especially with class relations
and class formations,
with sexual divisions,
with racial structuring
of social relations,
and with age oppressions
as a form of dependency.
Got it?
[chuckling]
OK.
The second one,
culture involves power
and helps to produce asymmetries
in the abilities of individuals
and social groups to define
and realize their needs.
And third one, culture
is neither autonomous
nor an externally
determined field,
but a site of social
difficulties and struggles.
Those ideas are really
important to keep in mind,
because this paper
also raises the idea--
I know it is a
social field, which
is kind of the combination
of all of the beliefs, myths,
aspirations, hopes of a part
of a society, of a culture,
and so it includes things
such as why racial hierarchies
exist, to why sexual
divisions exist,
and like what roles gender
people play in a society.
And it's really important
to keep that in mind,
because if you're able
then you're able to think
critically about that.
And through the critical
process of engaging with it,
you're able to change
the social field.
And so I think that
that's important,
because even though
this paper raises
a lot of really powerful
ideas, it's still not perfect.
So one of the
quotes of this paper
is, "Literacy's oral
dimension is important,
even if it takes place
in a culture, like that
of the United States, whose
memory is predominantly
written, not oral,
like that of Africa."
Africa is not
(LAUGHING) country.
And so something like that is
also part of the social field,
and would make it
into this paper.
Because even though Freire and
Macedo are thinking critically
about this, they
are not engaging
with the full reality of
cultural objectivity and being
subjects within that.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
So in the next
article, Paulo Freire
talks about the use of language
as a form of resistance.
And he first starts
talking about how
the current traditional methods
in literacy how they tend
to ignore the
importance of language
in a person's education.
And he bases a lot of his
theories on his experiences.
And from the second quote he
says that, "The sad reality
is that while
education in Portuguese
provides access to positions
of political and economic power
for the higher echelon
of African society,
it screens out the
majority of the masses, who
fail to learn
Portuguese well enough
to acquire the necessary
literacy skills for social,
economic, and
political advancement."
And you definitely-- from the
way that he mentions this,
you could definitely see
a lot of like correlations
between what's going on
around the world and currently
in the United States.
And you could definitely
see that the 1%
usually have the most
control over things,
and that they usually tends to
drive how policies are made.
But the fact is that
when a person is taught
in their native language, they
tend to learn things better
and comprehend things faster.
And can we go to the next slide?
There's usually backlash when
it comes to different languages
taught in schools.
For example, in
the US, people say
that students should learn
how to speak standard American
English.
But when it comes to providing
these sort of opportunities
to minority groups of,
I guess for instance,
like students of
color, there is usually
some racial tensions
that develop
that make minority
students feel inferior.
For example, there was
an article mentioned
of like recently, like
March of 2017, that
talked about a robotics
team that recently had won
the challenge, and the fact
that after they had won
the students-- or I
guess people in the crowd
started screaming
at them and telling
them to go back to Mexico.
And so this form of like
demeaning commentary
tends to drive the dropout
rates of minority groups,
and all of this tends to
contribute to like the prison--
sorry, the school
to prison pipeline.
As you can see in
the infographic,
it gives a lot of
percentages talking
about this sort of issue.
You can see in the
bottom, it says
that 68% of all males in
state and federal prison they
do not have a high
school diploma.
And this tends to be--
gives statistics on students.
And all of this tends
to stem from the fact
that minority
students do not have
the same access to education
as the elite part of society.
And from personal experience, I
can definitely relate to this.
I went to a school about like an
hour and a half from my house,
and I definitely did have a lot
of good role models growing up.
But were definitely students
around my neighborhood
that didn't have the same
access to the same opportunities
that I did.
Some of them did drop
out to start working.
Others were influenced by
gangs around my neighborhood.
And you could definitely--
things are definitely
getting better,
but things could
definitely be improved
from an emancipatory
literacy approach, which
is what Paulo Freire mentions.
Yeah.
So in emancipatory
literacy, this
involves using the
language of the people,
rather than the elites.
It teaches students to
accept their experiences
and their culture.
And this moves from the
world of objectivity
to the world of subjectivity,
where individuals learn
to accept themselves
for who they are,
rather than feel like
they're a victim of society.
And Paulo Freire does
mention that achieving
emancipatory literacy is
hard, but it's not impossible.
And now I'll-- and so Lorraine
wants to talk about a few
examples of how this
is being used today.
So considering specifically
the case of Haiti--
which Michel works a lot on,
the MIT Haiti initiative--
virtually all of the schooling
in both K through 12 education
and then in higher education
is done in French, and not
in Kreyol.
But the problem is that most
people only speak Kreyol
fluently, so like 95% or
so, and very few people
speak French fluently, at all.
So when you go through school,
and everything is in a language
that you don't
understand, how are you
supposed to be able to actually
get any of the education,
get any of this
social engagement,
especially if
children are punished
for speaking Kreyol in school.
And they can't interact
with each other,
can't ask questions,
can't gather
any of the information
that's coming at them.
So it's based on this false
belief and really outdated
belief about the
hierarchy of languages,
about which languages are
created or are younger,
or anything like that, and that
Kreyol isn't developed enough
to be able to be used for
technical language for STEM
education to have anything
translated into Kreyol.
And part of that is
saying that like Kreyol
isn't widespread enough,
even though Kreyol
has almost 10 million speakers.
Finnish has only about
5.5 million speakers,
and yet in Finland all of that
education is done in Finnish.
And people have-- studies have
found that, in Finland, kids
are much better equipped
to be able to learn
a second language, and to
go into higher education
and gather all of these
like technical studies,
because all of their
education is done in Finnish.
And over at IAP, I was doing
MISTI GTL in the Catalonia
region, in Spain, and there
Catalan also has a little
under 10 million speakers.
But in Catalonia
all of the education
is in Catalan, which
made it difficult for me
as like a "Spanish
speaker"-- like not even
fluent, but trying to
speak Spanish speaker--
to be able to
teach the students.
But they had such
a better experience
with all of their
textbooks in Catalan
all of their computer software.
So I was trying to teach
them Inkscape and Gimp,
but everything was is
(CHUCKLING) Catalan,
and I just couldn't understand
like even how to open a window.
So they taught me
a lot about this.
And they-- all of
them speak Catalan,
and Spanish, and
English, and then they
can like learn German or
French on the side, as well.
So all of them, because
their initial education
K through 12 and then
higher education,
if they want it to be,
is in Catalan, then
they can learn all
of these other things
just as well as we do like
in English, which is mostly
our one and kind of only
language in the United States.
Yeah.
So that was my experience.
And what-- a school that is like
a really good model in Haiti
is the LKM School.
I didn't know how to pronounce
it in Kreyol, so it's LKM.
It's a K through 10
school in a rural part
on an island of Haiti,
and their education
is starting to be in this
model of all Kreyol education,
trying to teach all
of these subjects, all
of the technical
terms in Kreyol.
And the students are
learning much better
than the rest of the students
in Haiti, who's schooling
is French and who only 10%
graduate from high school.
So the linguistic
apartheid part of this
is that, when you teach somebody
in a language they don't
understand, you
prevent them from being
able to move into different
socioeconomic classes
to attain the education
and the success
that they should be able to.
And this all leads to
the MIT Haiti initiative
that Michel started
here between MIT and all
the Haitian education systems.
So a couple of their main points
are to teach educators in Haiti
that teaching in Kreyol
is perfectly fine,
that it is actually
better for the students,
that it gives them
more opportunities,
and that STEM and
technical subjects
can be taught in Kreyol.
So a lot of the
worries or concerns
are that like Kreyol doesn't
have words for these languages.
We didn't have
words for a computer
either up until when
they were created.
A lot of other languages borrow
words from other languages.
So I learned Japanese,
and in Japanese there's
this lovely thing called
[speaking japanese]
where you just grab words
from other languages.
So if you don't know
how to pronounce it,
you kind of like make
it sound like it,
and oftentimes, it is
what has been borrowed.
So for example, bread
is pan, from German.
And all of these
other languages have
words borrowed from
other languages,
and that's what
globalization does.
So the same thing should be able
to happen with Kreyol and STEM
learning.
And the really good
results of this
are that they affirm students'
cultures and backgrounds,
and their own upbringings, and
how the society actually works,
as opposed to a colonial
oppressive society.
And it equalizes students
being able to have
more social mobility, and
to attain what they want
and what they should be able to.
GUEST SPEAKER: So
to kind of tie this
back to what we can do to stay
woke, with regards to literacy,
I think it's important
to remember that,
"language is a mediating
force of knowledge,
but it is also
knowledge itself."
And so one approach
is for groups
to kind of come together
and create a language that
describes their experience
amongst themselves,
and then to share that language
and to share that experience
in their own language.
And I think that that is one way
that we can start breaking away
from the kind of putting
standard English on a pedestal,
and can also kind of
validate other discourses,
and other ways of being,
and of other just languages
that kind of already exist in
the US and across the world.
Questions.
How have our
understandings of literacy
evolved in response
to the internet,
unprecedented
global integration,
and increased pressure
to preserve human rights?
For example, what does
it mean that schools
repress the development
of subjectivity,
but do largely ensure literacy?
How can modern
notions of literacy
evolve to address the phenomena,
such as the proliferation
of fake news?
So if we're moving past literacy
as just the idea of being
able to read, and
we are entering
this new kind of this new
wave being defiantly pushed
by the internet and the
influence of technology
on the way we live,
literacy is coming
to be a more critical
approach to life in the sense
that fake news is
a thing, you know,
and it's actually quite hard to
distinguish what news is really
what news is fake.
And the ability to do that,
having that critical lens,
is maybe the next
evolution of literacy.
So any ideas on that, I
guess, is the question.
AUDIENCE: So I'm just gonna
answer the first part of this,
because I'm not sure if I have
an answer for the next two.
But something that
I think is kind of
hilarious about like the
integration of the internet
is that I think it's
simultaneously making us more
literate and less literate.
So like-- or like pressuring
you to be more literate.
So "pressuring" you
to be more literate
is like, now there's a bunch
of sources that you can read,
and like now you can
be more educated,
it's all open to the public
if you have a computer.
And then there's also
like the pressure
to speak English properly,
based off either, you know,
like there's one viral video,
this old grandma screaming
at this Hispanic woman
in IHOP because she
was paying in Spanish,
or something like that.
So like it puts pressure on
you to speak English correctly,
and then meanwhile, because
of like things like Facebook
and like any social
media, people
like don't speak English
correctly, like typing,
you know,
abbreviations and stuff
that's acceptable in text,
but like meanwhile we're
saying you should
speak English properly.
So it's kind of a
weird dichotomy.
GUEST SPEAKER: I'm
interested in the age
implications of what you
just said, kind of aligning--
kind of a critique towards
the use of different varieties
of English with older
generations and the use
of nonstandard
varieties of English
with younger generations.
I'm interested in that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think--
I mean, I guess like--
so like there's a grandma that
I know that's on Facebook,
and like she makes sure
to type everything out,
including punctuation.
And like her Facebook
posts are longer
and they're more like here's
a card, that type of thing.
Whereas like my Facebook,
A, I'm just sharing things,
but B, if I write
anything, it's probably
not good, proper English.
So I think it does
depend on your age group,
but also like going back to the
original point of, you know,
that grandma screaming
at the Hispanic woman
in IHOP, like it's not just
like an older woman screaming
because, you know,
she's more literate.
Like there's also like
kids who think like, oh,
you have to speak
English in here.
So like there is still that
weirdness between like how
older people act on Facebook,
and stuff like that.
But I still think like the point
of, you know, pressuring people
is regardless of age.
AUDIENCE: I think
because we're gonna
be talking about language,
which is dialect in this class,
I would kind of risk
saying that we're
kind of creating a new language
because of the internet
with like all the
abbreviations and things.
And there's the way--
the push for speed and
everything like that.
So I think the reason
that older generations
don't use it as much is
because they're not used to it,
and they're in a different
frame of reference
and they just haven't learned
this new dialect that we're
starting to use.
So I think that it's a
good thing, in a sense,
but a lot of people who
want that standard American
English are going to be
pushing us to go back to that,
as opposed to using
the internet language.
But going as far as our
changes in literacy because
of the internet, like I didn't
know if the ending was satire,
at first.
Well, I just didn't know
that the ending existed.
And then when I saw that, I
realized that that was satire.
I think that nuance
like that is something
that you miss especially
with the internet,
because you can't really express
sarcasm very clearly over just
plain text.
And I think that's something
that we're like struggling
with, because of the internet.
AUDIENCE: But I
think that you said--
you talked about The Onion.
I think that shows like Stephen
Colbert or the Colbert Report,
and shows like
that, show that we
have been dealing with that
sort of satire language issue.
Because for a long
time, people rushed
[inaudible] didn't realize
that it was satire.
So I think that we've
done this before,
and it's sort of
a different cycle.
Now it's on the net
instead of being TV.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to bounce
off what you originally said.
Like with like it's
not a bad thing
that we're checking
the language,
I agree with thi It's
kind of like [inaudible],,
as you mentioned.
Do you think like there
are certain rules,
like the way we type,
and like is there
like a way to be literate like
with our new abbreviations?
AUDIENCE: I think
there definitely is.
Like for instance, punctuating
sentences with like LOL or ha
ha.
Like the beginning of the
end, where you put that.
Using emojis to get
more emotion in it.
Like there's definitely
like a science to it
that we kind of fell into, but
didn't realize was [inaudible]..
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
OK, cool.
I understand what you're saying.
GUEST SPEAKER: My question
is, so knowing now
that people grow up in
the type of literacy,
whether it's traditional
or emancipatory,
what are the pros and cons
of your type of literacy?
And explain why we should
move towards or away
from an emancipatory literacy.
AUDIENCE: I think you all
gave some really great points
towards moving to
emancipatory literacy.
I mean, if it's helping people
learn, I don't see a down fall,
especially because it's kind
of broadening their world view.
A couple of presentations
ago, there were other students
who were playing
jeopardy with AAE,
and that was kind of like
broadening their worldview.
Like even if you
went to the school
and didn't speak AAE you were
learning about a new language
that you weren't familiar with.
And so they were able to do this
through the emancipatory sort
literacy.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: What's AAE?
AUDIENCE: Oh,
African-American English.
Sorry.
Not AAPE.
AUDIENCE: So kind of just
playing devil's advocate
a little bit, I think--
I guess one of the dangers
of emancipatory literacy
might be kind of this
non-standardization
like with issues like Common
Core and things like that.
We kind of have an
educational system
that's set up so that
everybody's kind of put
on the same level,
to some extent.
Like everybody has that same
kind of baseline education.
But like with
emancipatory literacy,
I think you're going to find
educational programs are more
geared towards a specific
like cultural norms
and things of that nature
related to whatever
population it targets.
So I wonder if that
could potentially
produce a system in
which certain students,
even though they're
receiving an education that
is geared towards them,
it's objectively not
that same quality
of student who are
receiving more of a traditional
Thwere's the approach.
[inaudible]
GUEST SPEAKER: I
want to push back
on that just a little
bit, because I think
that the standardized
approach to education
is the approach that's
been taken with, you know,
teach for a test
approach, and it's failed.
It's been failing
for a while now,
and I think that a lot of people
in education policy and even
just teachers are
recognizing that now.
And I think that education--
emancipatory literacy gives
us an interesting lens
to think about how to educate
people so that they can learn.
And I think maybe
another place you
can start kind of
investing energy
is thinking of ways in
society that we can value
those different ways of
knowing and being and learning,
so that it's not just,
you went to college,
so you deserve to be paid a
lot of money kind of thing,
and it's a, oh you can
build a table from scratch.
How do you get paid to do that?
AUDIENCE: Where do
you think MIT falls
on the spectrum of like
emancipatory literacy?
[laughing]
GUEST SPEAKER: I think MIT
is way far on the tradition.
MIT is the Alt right of
traditional literacy, I think.
[laughing]
I just think that there are--
I think that the
immense pressure that
falls on students, just on
students physical bodies,
is definitely a symptom
of a larger problem.
And for me, the fact
that that symptom is not
enough of an impetus to
change, is heartbreaking.
Because I think that--
I didn't come to
college expecting
it to be the best
four years of my life,
but I didn't come here also
expecting to just suffer.
[laughing]
And so I think that
there's definitely
got to be a way
where I can bloom,
can reach my best potential.
And I love learning.
I love-- like I love
school, you know,
and the fact that I have
just kept running up
against the institution, I
think, as a creative person,
has made me kind of step
back and think again
about emancipatory literacy
and how I can do that after.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: So I have a
question for you, Cynthia.
So given what you
just said, how would
you-- so if you were
to be MIT's president,
what would you change?
What-- how would you make
it better more emancipatory?
Keeping in mind that
there are certain goals
that you have to reach
in terms of, say,
chemical engineering,
if you're a chemist,
how would you do that?
How would you advise
administration be better
on that score?
CYNTHIA: I think very
first thing I would do
is have people who are
more interested in research
not be professors.
So the ones who are
interested in research
should be doing
research full time,
and the people who are
interested in teaching
should teach.
Because I think that
that gives like--
that gives people
more impetus just
to connect with their students
and actually get to know them,
and I think in that
kind of environment,
you would foster like a
safer, healthier environment
for learning.
Whereas if you have
a professor who
is more interested in
winning the Nobel Prize,
like what are you-- what do
you do coming up against that?
I also would have MIT think
very, very hard about where
the funding is coming from?
What it's going to?
And how that kind of fits
in the global system, where
MIT as an institution fits
into the global system,
as kind of not only
an institution that
does propel you to a
higher class, but kind of
does that at the expense
of a lot of other people
and systems across the globe
even if it's not directly
in the area.
So I think that being more
critical and intentional
about our values, and
also maybe adding soul
to the end of that--
end of the that motto.
But--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK, OK.
CYNTHIA: Yeah.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Attention
to the third question.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: The last question is,
from your personal experiences,
or what you've
seen or read about,
how do you think we can
improve students' experiences
and confidence through
intentional language
use in schools?
Like what mottoes do you think
are working, or would work?
TEACHING ASSISTANT: Dana?
AUDIENCE: Well there's a model,
the only one of it's kind,
it's in Canada, it's a Mohawk
language immersion school
that's K through six, but it
struggles to secure funding
because it also doesn't
follow a standardized Canadian
curriculum.
In fact the community has sort
of decolonized the curriculum,
and they teach history, for
instance not Canadian history,
they teach Mohawk
history, and it's
been really affirming
for children
in the community,
Especially a community that
has its own struggles
with language preservation
and revitalization, and
passing on the language
to continued generations.
Especially after a history of
residential schooling that--
main aim was a cultural
and linguistic genocide
of these people.
So this is a great model,
but it's funded entirely
by community fundraisers
and every year
struggles with staying open.
And it's never certain
that it will be there
in the next school year.
But it seems to have
had a really, really
a positive impact on the
Mohawk community in Canada.
And so programs like that I
think need to now be funded,
and that involves challenging
our federal and local
requirements for funding, and to
do that we need to interrogate
what value there is in
the curriculum we have
standardized, and why that
is considered objectively
the standard that should
impart the best learning
experience upon students?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Go ahead Colin.
AUDIENCE: So bouncing
of that it seems
we get to [inaudible]
thing where it [inaudible]
is inculcated in this
standard curriculum.
It goes into society
and then perpetuates
the standard curriculum
back on the Indian students.
So I'm curious about
if anyone has thoughts
how you could make knowledge
about-- because one
of the main hurdles is people
instituting, or interrogating
the standard curriculum
is just strictly about how
the story of America's history
has been with regarding
the Native American
genocide, slavery,
and, for lack of a
better word, mean
that it is manifest destiny.
How do you make people
aware of that on a level
that they can see those
things playing out today,
then work to interrogate
that curriculum?
Especially if they are
coming from a background
where race isn't talked about
in this family because it's
an uncomfortable
topic, or if they just
haven't heard about these things
necessarily because of school.
AUDIENCE: For me, I feel
like it's more about where
do you learn to interrogate
your own beliefs,
and I feel like
that's hard to find.
And I came to-- this class was
a huge part of that for me.
And I don't know if that
because I started out,
or if I just happened
to stumble upon a place
where I learned to
interrogate my own beliefs.
But I think this isn't a
point to make for themselves,
but I don't really have an
answer for how we get triple
the value in evaluating in
interrogating your own beliefs,
or how much more in [inaudible]
learn to interrogate your own
beliefs before attacking
someone else's.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, bouncing off
of I think a common theme
that we come up in
this class is how
do we have conversations
with people who don't
want to these conversations?
And I think the only way
for them to figure it out is
for them to
interrogate themselves,
but most of those people won't.
So finding ways to make
them interrogate themselves,
I think is gonna be a common
problem throughout history.
And unfortunately I
don't know I, personally,
have a great solution for that.
But I think more
opportunities like this--
I mean obviously you mentioned
this before, the people who
are taking this class,
were not really diversified
at all right?
We all sought this
class out mostly,
so I don't know how
you can get someone
who doesn't want
interrogate themselves
in to a situation like this.
So maybe mandating
something like this
where you have to
go a black history
class, or a Native
American history class,
or whatever might force people
to start talking about it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I almost
think it might be better
to not have a
separate class where
this is your
well-roundedness class,
this is where we're going
to learn about the others.
But to integrate
what you would learn
in a specific
black history class
into the general curriculum.
Which of course is
harder, but I do
think would require the
same amount of conversations
and connections,
and negotiations
as making a requirement
of a separate class.
But I think that a
better approach that
might be more palatable and
have more positive effects
would be just straight up
integration, decolonizing
the current curriculum.
CYNTHIA: I totally-
AUDIENCE: Yeah, go ahead.
CYNTHIA: I was going to say
I totally agree with Dana,
I think that--
I'm losing my train of thought--
I totally agree
with Dana because I
think that the history
will speak for itself.
I think that history is--
if you know the full history of
the United States for example--
it's pretty terrible
and I think that you
do need to know
the whole history,
and also need to get
the alternative sides
and have those be integrated
into the curriculum.
I also was interested in
thinking about entry points
into these
conversations, and ways
that our humor can
function as entry
points in these conversations.
I've been having
this conversation
with a friend of mine of
how humor, for example,
gives us a way to
kind of express
some of these things
that are more taboo,
and kind of laugh them off,
and kind of integrate them,
as opposed to
everyone shunning them
and people feeling bottled.
So I am interested
about humor and art
specifically as entry point
into these conversations.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: [inaudible].
So Dana, I think
what you say in a way
answers the concern that
Shope expressed right?
Because Shope put
it as dual choice.
That you either do this
or you do that, right?
So Dana is right, right Shope,?
One can imagine
having in the class--
the principle math
class, chemistry class--
paying attention
to those issues.
In fact there room
for that, even
if you take a simple
photography class
one can even think about
what kind of choices
go into making your camera?
And actually, I have friends
who are photographers
and they explain to me that
actually most cameras were not
geared to take pictures
of black people.
So even as a white
photographer he
finds that when he takes a
picture with his regular Cannon
of a white person it comes
much better than when
takes it of a black person.
Why?
Because the lenses are
designed with a normal gaze
of the white subject right?
So he had to tweak his
camera to make it take
good pictures of black people.
So even there, even
in physics there's
a way to interrogate
the curriculum.
Why selections are made
with the lens for example?
So in a way it could
both, you could
both have the necessary interest
in human beings the quote
unquote more
"traditional curriculum".
And going back to
the other point,
can you imagine also
in history, in biology,
biology could include
text like I mentioned
earlier, The Mismeasure
of Man if you wish,
goes into lots of integral
issues about biology.
About how we make--
heads were measured
to show that humans
are as intelligent.
At Harvard for
example, for many years
when you were coming
in you had to undress
and they took your
picture naked,
and they would at your picture
to decide what kind of students
you would become based
on physical traits,
like because your head.
This was Harvard.
I guess this was one
proponent of what
was called then phrenology.
Which is the measure of--
So there is plenty,
plenty of room
to integrate those
kind intricacies
within traditional curriculum.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and I want
to express the fact that
to do such a thing is
not just to include
all of the hushed
historical abuses
that we gloss over in
our current curricula.
But it's also to acknowledge the
good that we have overlooked.
So discoveries and innovations
that other people who are not
quote unquote "western", and
who are not Anglo-American
have made and contributed
to the fields of science,
and history, and literature.
So not only to recognize
these historical evils,
but also the grand positive
impacts that others have had.
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
Absolutely, absolutely.
So are you guys happy
with the answers?
[laughter] OK, so
thank you very much.
[applause]